there seems to be a lot of conversation
about my Twitter account over the last
day or two it all started with this
tweet which is now garnered over 12 and
a half thousand likes laser eyes are
gone and Bitcoin in the bio gone maybe
I'll start talking about dividend stocks
next and then there were other tweets
from people in the crypto Community
including this one comparing past
versions of my profile to the current
version today I even got phone calls and
text messages from a number of people
that I greatly respect they wanted to
know what was going on did I change my
mind on bitcoin did I sell my Bitcoin
what the hell was happening the truth is
I haven't changed my mind I still hold
Bitcoin and my conviction is deeper than
ever both personally and professionally
I've actually been buying more Bitcoin
over the last couple of months but while
I may not have changed my mind on
Bitcoin in its future prospects there
are a number of things that have changed
the first lesson is that Bitcoin will
humble you I have been one of the
loudest and most public proponents of
Bitcoin over the last half decade it has
allowed me all sorts of benefits I've
traveled the world and I have gotten
more opportunities than I could have
ever dreamed of I'm incredibly thankful
for these and it isn't lost on me how
much of my life has improved because of
Bitcoin but there are two essential
rules on the internet never believe your
own [ __ ] and never become the main
character back in June of 2019 I
predicted that bitcoin's price would
rise to a hundred thousand dollars by
the end of 2021 while Bitcoin did not go
up approximately 8X from that point it
did go up 6X and there's a lot of people
who would argue the difference doesn't
really matter but at the end of the day
I was wrong and it was a great reminder
that humans can't predict the future in
price predictions are a Fool's game
Bitcoin helped to Humble me now in
regards to the idea of becoming the main
character this is a lesson that I
recently learned the internet is a weird
weird wild place a nobody can become a
somebody really quick but as with
everything in life too much of a good
thing can ruin it and the problem with
becoming the main character is that you
can fool yourself into believing that
you actually know more than you do
people start to see you as the teacher
but that's not who I am I relish the
role of being the student I know nothing
and I am hungry to learn it's really
hard to ask dumb questions and learn
when everyone thinks that you know it
already they would say you're on
television you're speaking at
conferences don't you have the answers
well no I don't I want to learn this is
a journey That Never Ends the second
part of this conversation is around the
idea of identity I have preached for
years to not tie your personal identity
to any company or organization but
rather the most powerful thing is to tie
your own identity to your personal name
be self-sovereign but I violated my own
advice over the last two years laser
eyes hashtag Bitcoin in the Twitter bio
it's all noise the truth is that it's
incredibly difficult to be an
independent thinker when your identity
is tied to a financial asset how can you
think critically if everything about
your public Persona is tied to that
financial asset can you really think
about an asset from both sides of the
table when it's sitting in your Twitter
bio would you be willing to change your
mind if it required you to shed your
entire identity maybe but it definitely
would make it much harder as I told a
friend a few months ago it's really hard
to see with laser eyes on the third
point is around building anyone who's
been around the Bitcoin ecosystem for a
number of years knows that bear markets
are the best time to build and that's
what I've been trying to do I've been
spending time with my team trying to
better run the companies that we own and
operate the most public company is a
company called inflection points Inc we
already have built the largest
employment product for the entire
ecosystem and we've helped more than 1
000 people get a job in the last 18
months now we're in the process of
scaling a corporate training program
which hopefully will bring Bitcoin to
hundreds of thousands of people over the
coming 12 months it's important to
remember that Twitter is not real life
there's an inverse correlation between
the amount of time you spend on Twitter
and the amount of things that you get
done now I love LARPing and doom
scrolling just as much as anyone but
that's not what bear markets are for it
is time to build tweeting isn't
conviction building is to make it
abundantly clear I still believe that a
finite asset with a programmatic
monetary policy will serve as the best
store of value with the backdrop of
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
in the Fiat world I don't need laser
eyes or hashtag Bitcoin in my Twitter
bio to hold those views I express my
opinion by simply stacking SATs and
continuing to buy Bitcoin I'm an
independent person who likes to think
critically I'm willing to change my mind
if I receive new information but my
conclusion is then Bitcoin will continue
to be the best store of value and I
don't see that changing anytime soon and
to the haters and trolls I love you
every single one of you you motivate me
to get better you make sure that I'm
motivated to learn and I wouldn't have
nearly the conviction I have if it
wasn't for you so thank you I appreciate
all the critiques all the feedback Keep
It Coming you haven't changed my mind
yet but keep trying and maybe one day
you'll finally be successful I hope all
of you understand that there's a lot of
people in Bear markets who have too much
time on their hands they float all kinds
of ideas and they make mountains out of
nothing my conviction hasn't changed and
anyone who says differently is just flat
out wrong